i have five or six questions and five
minutes um but let's see what i can do
and you've got me to answer them you are
gone yeah no
i know um so the first thing is eight
minutes okay go go oh
by all means you give me 20.
give me whatever you want to give me um
so there is have you seen the video of
you
the footage from the trailer of you
whistling and it leading into jurassic
park with you reacting to the dinosaurs
though
okay
you need to i'm going to i'll put it in
this in the article um
getting serious um this movie is
fantastic and as usual you are so good
in it i am curious though this might be
the least amount of exposition i've ever
seen in a movie which i loved what was
it like actually reading the script
because it's so sparse with dialogue
it's a joy it's what cinema is uh at its
best for me when i was growing up those
were the films that made me lean in it's
not really about
there is a lot of plot in this it's just
it's taken through four people's journey
in this extraordinary landscape this
isolating experience of being on a ranch
and being at loggerheads with each other
and the miscommunication
and the complexity the sort of
psychodrama thriller aspect about how it
motors to a conclusion
these most people are pretty shocked i
would say a lot does happen by the end
of the film however yeah i i understand
it's a slow burn and it's a lean in kind
of a movie
and
[Music]
there aren't many made like that anymore
and there is that god from a lot of the
reaction we've had at least that this
there is a cultural space for this
and i just think to be able to examine
especially with jane's sensitivity and
sensual lens and aries work and johnny
greenwood's score and grant's amazing
extraordinary recreation 1925 montana
and the cast and the material it's it's
it's a rich treat and
it's the film that rewards repeat
viewing because
every time you see it there's another
layer there's another nuance there's
another clue there's another inference
and there's another journey that you go
on with these characters
i mean phil for example he's so led you
you see him as this abhorrent male
uh toxic male who's
punching down a soft target of his
brother's wife to shame her into
alcoholism um through sort of
psychologically gaslighting her and yet
you by the end of the film you
understand this is a man who bears deep
scars and a secret and an inauthenticity
uh that he's been living with because he
can't be his true self and
it's his tragedy in a way because of
that and
i don't know the film that lifts the lid
on toxic masculinity and asks why that
kind of behavior can be prevalent then
and then as in 60s when it was written
and then now still in
2021
i think that makes it kind of relevant
and
and a difficult and awkward watch but an
important one and
yeah yeah you
i i like film i like cinema i like stuff
where you're just you're let alone as an
audience you're not told what to think
you're not dragged into the next
madcap chase or monster fight sequence
or
plot turn around
you are you are just saturated in a
world and an experience
one of the things is i heard all about
how you really went for it in terms of
doing all this research staying in
character on set um and i'm just curious
how tough was it when you wrapped on the
film to let phil go like how long did it
take for you to become back to being
benedict on a daily basis it was it was
fine we had a long journey in the south
island at least a little less long uh in
auckland but by then we had the pandemic
so the whole psychology of it was so
different
um
and i'll explain that in a minute but
basically going back to new zealand and
destroyed the south island it was about
an hour and a half journey in and out so
i had a long time to prepare to meditate
to see and feel the landscape to start
simulating what i was going to bring of
him to the day's work and
and then the same going home i'd take
those sweaty
chaps and overalls off and i'd get in a
car and i'd either you know have a beer
or whatever and just open the window
stare at the stars or um or the sun set
whatever was happening and just breathe
the cyber leaf turn to scotty he was my
right-hand man through the whole shoot
and the whole pandemic
and have a laugh and get home to my
family there's nothing more grounding
than that um so yeah i i didn't find it
difficult to let go on a daily basis and
i really enjoyed putting those sweaty
overalls on the next day because he's
such a rich complex amazing gift of a
character to carry a secret and to also
reveal a secret in a film especially a
jane campion one where she's so she asks
for so much authenticity and
really helps you to get there with it as
well through process through
augmenting any kind of pre-production
prep i got to go to dude camp i got to
experience life on a ranch i did
everything that i do on the film for
real
um and i rode a lot and then summoned
the banjo playing and i did taxidermy
and i did iron my green all the gifts
this
man is uh is blessed with uh in the book
that don't even make the film to
understand who he is to feel who he is
to sense
what it's like to be in his body and his
mindset
that was just
that wasn't an obstacle that wasn't
difficult that was an extraordinary
journey and a really enriching one for
me and then to be allowed to be him from
you know the beginning of the shooting
day to the end was a gift she introduced
me to the
i'm quite apologetic i'm quite um
sort of a bit of a people pleaser and
that can creep into my work on set even
if i'm playing someone objectionable i
feel embarrassed about i have to
apologize after a take or something
british and uh she went look uh you're
gonna meet this is phil uh you'll meet
benedict at the end benedict's really
nice this is phil
so i just got to be i got to be him and
i didn't worry for a second about
apart from maybe the first day where i
thought who the hell am i to deserve
this kind of
sacrifice of a crew of growing up men
and women pretending i really am this
guy but by the end of the first day i i
was in it
it was in it and that's a
that's a real springboard for
authenticity so yeah
thank you jane
yeah dude
as usual but your performance and this
is just so good i'm out of time i'm just
going to say
thank you so much for giving me a few
minutes of your time looking forward to
the next you know what i mean i know
what you mean yeah we'll talk about that
soon i'm sure
exactly
all right lots of love